this video was sponsored by North Vee
peon and this is to go even further
beyond screaming explosions and long
golden locks sitting as the crown jewel
of iconic moments for many Dragon Ball
fans comes Goku's first transformation
into the legendary super saiyan 3
sporting more hair more screams and less
eyebrows the fun show until nature of
this scene mixed with its bombastic
light show and in some cases soundtracks
create a one-of-a-kind atmosphere so
today I want to take a look at and
review four versions of this scene to
see which is the best in your eyes going
in order of release
I will first take a look at the original
manga chapter from 1994 the original
Japanese broadcast from the same year
followed by the English Funimation edit
and dub from 2002 capping it all off
with Dragon Ball Z Kai Zrii dubbed
version from the year 2014 and 2017 but
before we start I'd like for you to vote
here in the top right and let me know
what your favorite version is before
watching this video and once I've broken
down the four verses of this scene I
will give you guys the chance to vote in
a second poll at the end and I want to
see if your pians have changed or stayed
the same and so with that explained
let's get the show rolling with the very
first time this legendary scene hit the
public eye and to do that we need to go
all the way back to the streets of Japan
in the mid-1990s originally released on
June 14 1994 via Weekly Shonen Jump
titled the limit Super Saiyan 3 this was
written and drawn entirely by Akira
Toriyama
and is about 13 pages long the chapter
itself picks up right after Goku
teleports in front of majin buu and
bobbidi in order to stall his
destruction
allowing trunks the time to find the
dragon radar in capsule Cork so let's
see how similar or different the manga
looks and reads the chapter kicks off
right after Goku announced that he'll
have to go past the Super Saiyan level
nice cliffhanger as piccolo questions
past Super Saiyan beyond the original
Goku is of course only doing this to buy
as much time as he can and as he stands
before Buu
Goku thinks to himself trunks your chief
stop moving will you get going don't
really want to do this as trunks just
floats they're in awe at Goku string
Goku shouts out for him to retrieve the
Raider and this is
perplexed bobbidi and majin buu focused
quickly returned to Goku as he powers
down to base form
Goku says I want to teach you about
Saiyans so it's easier to understand
from this point Goku proceeds to go
through all of his super saiyan
transformations by the time this chapter
was released a cure Toriyama had been
drawing and writing the Dragon Ball
story for almost ten years over that
decade his art style changed
considerably going from round and soft
and early Dragonball to sharp and jagged
by the vows ugh however by the time the
Buu saga came around it was clear that
Akira Toriyama had been burned out on
the series and I think that burnout
slipped through in some of the panels he
produced during that time period when
compared with prior arcs that's not to
say I think it's bad or that people
can't love it
that was just my impression of this
particular sections artwork I will be
sure to point out all the wonderful
illustrations I think are in this
chapter to the scene pushes on as Goku
proceeds to demonstrate his power ups he
bursts into Super Saiyan and pushes
himself further into Super Saiyan 2 but
fun fact despite the first Super Saiyan
2 being going back in the cell saga the
name Super Saiyan 2 was first used by
Goku in this very scene up until this
point it had been referred to as an
ascended Super Saiyan bhavati at this
point isn't impressed for claiming that
he can barely notice a difference and
that's when Goku pushes for a next level
the powerup itself takes up two full
pages with the third being the reveal of
Goku Super Saiyan 3 in a full-page
spread the panel itself features one of
the few times Akira Toriyama used
mid-tones
it's a terrific illustration Buu goes on
to remark that he looks scary but that
he's not afraid bobbidi then instructs
foo to finish him off and in that
instant Goku begins his assault on majin
buu which involves some of my favorite
panels from this arc goku throws boom
into the water but he bounces back
almost immediately barring a barrage of
blasts towards the saying that he blocks
with relative ease
as blue flies closer Goku notices that
his attacks haven't hurt him at all in a
flash blue stretches his arm to sucker
punch Goku in the face however both he
and Buu are left smiling in the end
leaving King Kai to scream if you keep
using your power you lose the time you
have left on earth and you still have to
teach Fusion to the kids and that
concludes the mangas chapter now let's
see how the other versions compare
starting with the original Japanese
broadcast original release November 9th
1994 first things first let's talk
filler during the conversation between
Goku bhavati and majin buu all the bases
are covered however the dialogue is
stretched out someone with Goku even
taking mental notes of boos seemingly
weak appearance additionally there's a
section towards the end that features
doctor briefs and trunks retrieving the
radar this isn't shown in the manga with
that said the episode proceeds as normal
covering all the bases as Goku powers
down into base form ready to give Buu
and bobbidi the best light show they've
ever seen
Goku bursts into Super Saiyan and Super
Saiyan 2
the scene differs visually from the
manga in that it gives a wider view of
the transformations themselves while
also providing the panels that Akira
Toriyama used in the manga this is a
great visual translation of the source
material adding to it for the sake of
visual flair during this the gang of the
lookout all speculate as to what Goku
might have up his sleeve when
[Music]
the artwork is magnificent in this scene
and the direction for the transformation
itself is breathtaking utilizing the
manga for direction but adding to it in
ways that make sense for an animation
medium electricity flashing aura sweat
droplets additional angles and
environmental animation through the
ocean cities and clouds building this up
to be the biggest and most spectacular
transformation in the series to date
someone interestingly there's an extra
cutscene showing Goku revert to an ape
his regular adult form and ultimately a
child as he explodes into a fully
realised Super Saiyan 3 with the color
palette lighting and final reveal
illustration speaking for itself the
fight that ensues proceeds as normal
however the action is prolonged and
stretched out in order to fit within the
runtime of that episode one final thing
of note is that the episode sports the
Kikuchi score which accompanied the
original run of Dragon Ball it's a score
that is still held in high regard
amongst the fans of this version today
but Before we jump ahead to the
Funimation dub I want to quickly thank
today's sponsor Nord VPN article 13 has
passed in Europe which means the
internet freedoms of millions of people
have been put at risk but thankfully
Nord VPN has given me peace of mind if
you follow the link in the description
Nord VPN comm four slash totally nut
mark and use coupon code holding on mark
you can get 75% off and protect yourself
for three years while getting an extra
month for free
don't let article 13 or net neutrality
dictate what you can do online protect
yourself with Nord VPNs military-grade
encryption enable it on your Android and
iOS devices and my personal favorite
never worry about region locks again
goes to Nord VPN comm forward slash
toilet mark and use coupon code tone up
mark to protect yourself online today
and so with that covered let's look at
how the early Funimation dub measures up
originally released on September 26 2002
over eight years after its original air
date in Japan folks in the West finally
got an English dub of this scene titled
Super Saiyan 3 the interpretation of
events is identical to the original
Japanese version visually that said
there are a host of differences from a
dialogue perspective so let's take a
look
Trunks is motivation to stop and stare
instead of retrieving the radar is
different in the manga he just stops
because
overwhelmed by Goku strength remarking
that he's as strong as his father before
he transforms further this is the moment
that triggers Goku to tell him to get
going in Funimation's version trunks
stops because he doesn't recognize the
power of Goku he explains that it might
be that monster and that Goku might need
his help
finally begging for someone to give him
a sign as to what he should do giving
Goku the cute to say Goku regains the
attention of Vava T and Buu as he powers
down demonstrating his base form he
elevates to super saiyan and eventually
Super Saiyan - explaining what they are
to the two evildoers
what follows is one of the most famous
performances by the English voice actor
of Goku mr. Shaw and Chimel what follows
are literal minutes of screaming and one
of the most famous brute Falkner tracks
in circulation the Super Saiyan 3 theme
the rest of the episode proceeds as
normal featuring in the Kikuchi scores
place as I mentioned earlier the Bruce
Faulkner score and with that one done
let's jump forward to our last version
Dragon Ball Kai entitled delay majin buu
the limit Super Saiyan 3 this episode
was redubbed and released on october 19
2014 in Japan but wouldn't be released
until September 23rd 2017 for
english-speaking audiences the driving
force behind the Dragon Ball Kai read
above the series was to essentially have
a recut streamlined version of the
original run of the Dragon Ball anime
aiming to cut out much of the filler
portions in the story where possible and
they pretty much did that with this
episode its pacing is noticeably faster
however with that said there are still
cutaways to the tournament grounds with
mr. Satan delivering speeches to the
audience the dialogue in the Japanese
version itself is just as faithful and
accurate as the initial broadcast from
the 90s was so let's focus and take a
look at the English dub of this section
the scene with trunks is stopping has
been restricted to be more in line with
the original Japanese broadcast trunks
now stops the remarks that Goku is as
strong as his dad was and Super Saiyan
to the confusion that was once there in
the original Funimation dub has been
replaced with shock and awe similar to
the manga and original broadcast there
isn't really much to comment on
regarding the subsequent powerup that I
haven't already pointed out it's just as
visually impressive in both performances
are just as great as they were in Prior
versions the music used is neither the
Kikuchi score or the Bruce Faulkner
tracks but the Sumitomo soundtrack
Sumitomo has since gone on to produce
the soundtracks for super and the Dragon
Ball super bro Lee movie something of
note is that a substantial amount of
criticism has been lobbed at Dragon Ball
Kai's visuals specifically during this
portion of the story the visuals have
been criticized as being overly
saturated in color and in some cases
poorly color corrected when compared
alongside the original series and so as
promised this is where things get really
interesting now that I have broken down
the original manga chapter from 1994 the
original Japanese broadcast from that
same year the Funimation dub from 2002
at Dragon Ball Kai's version from 2014
and 7
I would like to present you with the
opportunity to cast your vote a second
time click here and let us know which
interpretation of the events outline do
you think presented at fest did your
opinion change or did it stay the same
let me know in the comments down below
I'm really interested to read your
thoughts at to see the results of this
video if you guys want to see more
videos like this one feel free to
subscribe I upload every Thursday and
don't forget to leave a like or dislike
on the video thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you all next week
[Music]
you